what do you believe evolution is
is it a force of nature a simple
algorithm encoded in the data of life or
perhaps a mathematical function like a
chaotic attractor or other emergent
phenomenon keep up the good work
and this is from chop resident
chop resident the chop house
the answer to that is that we've talked
about this a little bit before
there are four parameters that cause a
pattern to become
common in the universe they have to do
with either
reproduction or the tendency to come
into being the
tendency to uh
be self-similar the tendency
to stick around once created
and the tendency to accumulate limited
materials
that's selection and it creates every
pattern
that is non-biotic you get into a biotic
milieu you add one thing to it which is
heredity then you get adaptation
and when you we say evolution typically
we mean adaptation
and the answer is this is an
automatic uh
it is in some sense a nearly
tautological consequence
of preconditions that will result in
patterns becoming more common and then
those
features that cause increases in
commonality accumulating through
adaptation
excellent um would you accept the
three-word definition
descent with modification well if we
you know if we're being literal about
what we think the question asker
means what do you believe evolution is
right i understand what they've asked
but the problem is
evolution which uh does not
involve anything interesting as its
product
is simply uh genetic change within a
population
over time but can't that be
crunched down to descent with
modification that can
but if you think that um that
is tantamount to adaptation which is
what people typically mean when they say
evolution
right then it's insufficient right it's
it's insufficient
um but evolution descent modification
change over time never good enough
i mean that's that's the thing that
people think they think and in fact i
was listening to an otherwise really
good podcast this morning in which the
author of this book who knew a lot about
what he was talking about but as usual
didn't really know anything about
evolution said you know that evolution
you know change that's what evolution is
like no rocks change over time and they
don't evolve
descent with modification is the
shortest
um definition that actually seems
inclusive
we have an insect that has invaded the
house and our epic tabby is
interested in eating it
you